bonjour monsieur le ministre merci
d'être avec nous sur sur le plateau de
BFM TV marque phénoménis de
l'agriculture d'abord je voudrais que
que l'on regarde ces ces images vous
aviez appelé ce matin à la
responsabilité à l'apaisement avant
cette cette manifestation à
Sainte-Soline on voit ces images de
violence vous les avez vu est-ce qu'on a
assisté au scénario du pire tout à
l'heure on a assisté au scénario qu'on
crée celui de l'expression de violence à
l'endroit des forces de l'ordre en
particulier des gendarmes donc il faut
vraiment saluer l'action et la maîtrise
face à des éléments totalement
radicalisés et par ailleurs très
nombreux et très armés
que par ailleurs la volonté qu'ils
avaient détruire des biens qui
appartiennent à des personnes ne soient
pas ne puissent pas vaincre aujourd'hui
mais on a évidemment face à nous des
éléments très radicalisés qui par leurs
actions n'ont pas d'autres motifs que
ceux de blesser voire de tuer des
gendarmes des forces de l'ordre qui ne
font qu'autre chose que faire respecter
l'État de droit et donc faire respecter
la République et la démocratie est-ce
qu'on sait combien ils étaient c'est ces
activistes et quel profil ils ont ils
sont clairement identifiés j'ai écouté
ce qu'a dit mon collègue et c'est les
éléments que nous avions et c'est pour
ça d'ailleurs que la manifestation avait
été interdite parce que nous avions des
éléments qui nous permettait de penser
qu'il y avait un millier environ de
personnes totalement dans la
confrontation et qui ne cherchent que la
confrontation ce n'est pas une
manifestation qui déjeuner ça c'est une
manifestation qui est générée pour faire
de la confrontation avec des gendarmes
avec les forces de l'ordre et donc c'est
pas du tout le même nature que d'autres
d'autres situations et donc on avait un
millier semble-t-il de personnes qui
étaient dans cette situation de vouloir
en découdre avec les forces de l'ordre
on a vu les images des gens qui brûlent
des voitures ou des la deuxième fois que
il y a des incidents sur Sainte Soline
la fois précédente il y a plus beaucoup
de gendarmes blessés il semble cette
fois-ci qui avait quand même beaucoup
plus
d'éléments de personnes du type black
bloc
ultra selon le ministre de l'intérieur
ça veut dire que sur ce dossier de de
Soline vous ne parvenez pas à peser le
débat est-ce qu'il faut
reprendre le dialogue ou pas sachant que
c'est un monsieur je dis est-ce que vous
croyez qu'on peut dialoguer avec des
gens je parle pas des Black Blocs
les violences elles sont issues de ces
gens-là évidemment mais non mais vous
parlez avec les non violents mais ces
gens-là on peut pas discuter avec ces
gens-là parce que ces gens-là ils ne
connaissent qu'une chose c'est la force
c'est la violence et c'est au fond de
renverser ce que sont les principes
généraux de la République ce que sont
les principes d'un dialogue qui doit
être un dialogue pacifique avec les uns
et les autres c'est un alibi en fait
pour ces gens là c'est un alibi enfin on
sait bien qu'il y a un certain nombre
d'éléments qu'on a retrouvé à notre qui
à Notre-Dame-des-Landes qui dans
d'autres dans d'autres sites ou d'autres
lieux qui font profession et œuvres
quotidiennes ou hebdomadaire à la place
de l'Opéra peut-être qu'ils étaient
aussi des incidents et par ailleurs sur
le fond enfin sur le fond sur la
question du dialogue c'est un projet ça
a été dit par votre interlocuteur
agriculteur et j'aurais salut aussi les
agriculteurs qui aujourd'hui sont
menacés physiquement dans leurs
exploitations tous ces gens là qui ont
paillettiné le travail des agriculteurs
parce qu'ils ont marché dans des champs
qui sont qui sont dans notre
alimentation de cet été mais violent ou
non violents ils ont quand même pas
respecté ce qui est le droit de
propriété et par ailleurs le travail des
autres mais c'est quand même quelque
chose qu'il faut dire mais il y a des
agriculteurs qui se sont engagés de
bonne foi avec des associations
environnementales avec des collectivités
locales je rappelle qu'un protocole qui
a été signé qui est le produit de 12 ans
de travail une dizaine d'années de
travail il y a eu du dialogue en amont
il y a eu beaucoup de dialogues en amont
il y a eu des projets qui ont évolué en
termes de volume pour tenir compte à la
fois de ce que disait les scientifiques
et de ce que disait parfois les
associations environnementales mais à la
fin quand le projet a passé tous les
écueils scientifiques et tous les écoles
juridiques si on considère que ça suffit
pas et qu'il y a que la violence parce
qu'on n'est pas d'accord alors à ce
moment-là on n'est plus en République et
on n'est plus en démocratie je voudrais
qu'on écoute si vous le permettez
Monsieur le Ministre Benoît bitault que
nous avions tout à l'heure qui est
heureux député Europe Écologie Nevers et
qui qui justifie cette mobilisation
c'est c'est violence par le fait que
l'État n'était pas attentif à tous les
recours qui avait été déposé contre ces
méga bassines
les 30 000 personnes qui étaient là
aujourd'hui dénoncent la manière dont
elles sont mises en place c'est-à-dire
qu'on n'a pas créé les conditions pour
que ça fonctionne pour que ça fonctionne
il faut restaurer la capacité des
bassins versants à retenir l'eau pour
que l'eau retenue sur des très résumés
André l'eau qu'on aura retenu parce
qu'on aura recréé permettent de
recharger les nappes souterraines et une
fois que les nappes souterraines on
pourra utiliser de l'eau pour satisfaire
l'ensemble des usages y compris ceux de
l'irrigation voilà maintenant qui disait
également que ces méga bassines ne
profiteraient qu'à 5% des des
agriculteurs qui n'a plus de 90% qui ne
pourraient pas en profiter
seulement donc tous les agriculteurs
n'ont pas accès à l'irrigations je tords
le coup un premier procès qui est fait à
l'agriculture deuxième élément monsieur
Vito manifestement qu'on n'est pas assez
de dossier le projet c'est de passer de
21 millions de mètres cubes sur les
saints de solides 21 millions de mètres
cubes prélevés en été à 6 millions de
mètres cubes prélevés en été le bergm
qui est le buneau recherche géologique
et minière qui qui analyse les nappes
dit que ce process ce projet il va
permettre qui est plus d'eau en été de
soutenir les étiages de faire en sorte
que les zones humides puissent être
maintenues alors que en ce moment elles
le sont moins donc c'est un projet
vertueux 21 millions 6 millions et on en
prend 6 millions d'hiver pour pouvoir
couvrir le besoin que nous allons
deuxième élément ce sont pas des nappes
profondes ce sont des nappes
superficielles ils ont donc des nappes
qui se remplissent vite mais qui se
vident très vite en particulier l'été et
donc c'est au moment où elle se
remplissent où il y a du trop-plein
qu'on peut prendre de l'eau pour faire
en sorte que en été qu'on en a besoin un
peu plus on puisse la prendre sur la
réserve d'hiver et donc c'est ça qui va
pas dans ce procès parce que ce procès
qui est fait vous agriculteurs c'est
pour ça que je le défends avec
l'ensemble du gouvernement Gérald
Darmanin Christophe Béchu parce que
c'est un projet un projet qui est
vertueux c'est un projet dans lequel les
agriculteurs s'engagent à réduire
l'utilisation de produits fin de
phytosanitaires c'est un pro a un projet
dans lequel les agriculteurs s'engagent
à réduire la consommation d'eau c'est un
projet dans lequel les agriculteurs
monsieur Biteau parle de haie dans
quelles agriculteurs s'engagent à planté
des et si ça c'est pas vertueux je sais
pas ce que c'est qu'un projet vertueux
et donc à la fin c'est avec la seule
explication qui nous donnera à la fin
c'est capable besoin d'eau or on a
besoin de projet de retenue et on voit
bien cet été dans d'autres endroits si
on n'avait pas Serre-Ponçon Serre-Ponçon
c'est un immense ouvrage qui a été fait
il y a 50 ans j'imagine qu'il y a 50 ans
Monsieur Biteau nous aurait expliqué ça
va maman il ne fallait pas le faire
aujourd'hui tout le monde s'en réjouit
les agriculteurs les gens qui s'occupent
de tourisme les associations
environnementales ça permet de maintenir
les étagères j'ai donc c'est ces gens
qui viennent vous donner des leçons et
qui ne tiennent pas compte à la fois de
l'administration juridique et par
ailleurs du scientifique il rentre pas
service aux choses
comment arriver à trouver un point
d'équilibre est-ce que ces scènes de
violence vont se reproduire oui dit
certains parce qu'on n'est pas écouté
comment arriver à arrondir les choses
rien ne justifie la violence on est bien
d'accord monsieur le ministre rien c'est
inexcusable inexplicable inacceptable et
les oui mais les ça suffit et tous ceux
qui viennent nous expliquer que la
violence deviendrait légitime pour telle
ou tel motif je leur dis tout de suite
ils font fausse route et ils trouveront
la République pas nous la République
[Musique]
de cette façon là et donc c'est bien ça
ce qui est à l'oeuvre on a eu le même
sujet sur Bur comme vous savez le centre
d'enfouissement on a le même sujet à
sainte-soling sinon ça accrédite la
thèse que vous n'êtes pas d'accord vous
vous détruisez le bien d'autrui vous
menacez
ici des agriculteurs ailleurs dans
d'autres circonstances des
parlementaires et ça vous donne droit à
vos demandes ça c'est pas possible mais
ça se fixe beaucoup sur des projets qui
ont très à l'écologie et et votre
gouvernement le président singulièrement
et la cible justement des parties des
écologistes les plus ultra justement qui
considère que vous n'en faites pas assez
vous n'avez pas assez vite et que vous
prenez pas la mesure de de la
dégradation de la crise moi je connais
un certain nombre d'écologie c'était
même beaucoup d'écologistes y compris
proches de moi qui défendent l'idée
qu'on soit sobre avec l'eau qu'on essaie
de faire évoluer les pratiques agricoles
et je partage ce point de vue là et qui
ne pense pas que c'est une manière
d'agir et qui ne pense pas que chaque
projet justifie de d'action de tel je
fais de nature vous avez des
méthaniseurs vous avez des gens aussi
ultra radicalisés vous avez des panneaux
photovoltaïques vous avez des gens mais
ils proposent quoi au fond au-delà de
détruire en permanence le bien d'autrui
ou simplement par la violence de donner
droit à une demande qui scientifiquement
en plus n'est pas démontré nous faisons
on a besoin de projets de réserves on a
besoin de projet énergétique on a besoin
de projets nucléaire on va on peut pas
être dans un dans une société qui parle
à violence règle son conflit mais par
exemple vous savez bien que vous dans
cette affaire la FNSEA est soutien votre
votre projet la Confédération paysanne
est contre on voit bien aussi qu'il y a
le le modèle agricole qui est défendu à
travers ce type de projet qui a un
modèle plutôt productiviste qu'un modèle
qui serait plus respectueux mais pardon
c'est un modèle qui est respectueux de
l'environnement je viens d'essayer de
vous expliquer qu'on réduit le
prélèvement d'eau
que il y a des pratiques et des
engagements des engagements qui ont été
signés contrairement à ce que font
certains qui retirent leur signature je
pense à Madame bateau d'un protocole qui
a été cessé de ministre de l'écologie
et députés de cette signé le protocole
qui est à la manifeste et qui a retiré
sa signature les agriculteurs qui ont
engagé leur signature ils sont engagés à
réduire puisque c'est le c'est le projet
lui-même et d'eux ils sont engagés à
changer les pratiques c'est donc
l'évolution du modèle qu'on engage et
donc ceux qui disent qu'on n'engage pas
le modèle perd son évolution il manque
il nous raconte pas la réalité des
choses ça veut pas dire qu'il faut pas
poursuivre à chaque fois qu'on a un
projet de cette nature il faut
poursuivre avec l'idée que l'eau est un
bien rare et que donc pour tout le monde
il y a la question de la sobriété mais
j'entends parfois certains dire c'est de
l'accaparement par les agriculteurs mais
les agriculteurs ils accaparent rien
l'eau les manifestants sont solides
pardon cette eau qui est mise sur les
champs c'est pour les agriculteurs ou
c'est pour nous nourrir
alors à ce moment-là tout forage est un
accaparement parce que quand je bois de
l'eau qui est l'issue d'un forage dans
une nappe phréatique je m'accapare de
l'eau mais de quoi parle-t-on c'est
cette eau est un bien commun et
l'alimentation est un bien commun et
nourrir les gens c'est un bien commun
donc on a besoin d'agriculteurs qui
portent des projets raisonnés
raisonnables durable nous sommes un pays
qui est plutôt vertueux quand vous
regardez à nos frontières plutôt au sud
on a plutôt préservé la nappe on a
besoin d'irrigation dans ce pays mais
peut-être est-ce qu'on pourrait pas
penser à évoluer sur des cultures qui
seraient moins gourmandes dans l'eau je
pense au maïs qui est une grande
consommatrice d'eau est-ce que on
pourrait pas travailler sur d'autres
modèles et commencer à les anticiper on
a deux chemins d'abord il y a des
variétés de maïs qui sont consommatrices
de 15 à 20 ou 30% de moins d'eau
deuxième élément on a un assolement qui
est en train d'évoluer dans un certain
nombre de territoires où il y a un peu
moins de maïs mais maïs ou pas maïs je
suis désolé de rappeler quelque chose
mais vous le savez aussi bien que moi
une plante ça a besoin d'eau
donc si c'est pas du maïs c'est autre
chose et cette manique on est cette
manière qu'on a de faire une plante un
bouc émissaire ici c'est le maïs c'est
une fausse route qu'on retrouve on a
besoin de maïs c'est une plante qui
stocke beaucoup de carbone c'est une
plante qui a besoin d'assez peu de
produits phytosanitaires simplement elle
a besoin d'eau en été c'est vrai et donc
elle est plus fragile qu'un blé par
exemple mais donc on a besoin parfois de
faire évoluer la seulement parfois de
raisonner différemment les choses je
voudrais qu'on élargisse peut-être un
peu si vous le permettez monsieur le
ministre à ces violences après cette
journée de violence et ce qu'elle me
relative qui est revenu à Sainte Soline
ce soir sur la journée de mardi 10e
journée de mobilisation contre la
réforme des retraites on a évoqué sur ce
plateau la convergence des des colères
des violences qui sont en train de
monter crescend donc on le voit ici à
Sainte-Soline on l'a vu ces derniers
jours à Paris
où va-t-elle s'arrêter comment peut-elle
s'arrêter cette cette violence avec
évidemment les forces de l'ordre qui
sont fatigués ça fait plusieurs jours
qu'elles sont mobilisés à Paris dans
certaines villes de province et sont
affronter cette nouvelle journée de
mobilisation et cette colère qui montre
comment fait-on pour faire baisser
l'attention pardon de dire je compare
pas ce qui s'est passé à Sainte-Sophie
parce que la violence saint-sauline ça a
été dit par Monsieur jeudis c'était déjà
au mois d'octobre et c'était même avant
donc la violence de Sainte-Sophie
c'est donc ces éléments là sur lesquels
il faut agir deuxième élément à
sainte-souligne c'est une manifestation
interdite pour le motif que je viens de
vous évoquer à Paris c'est des
manifestations autorisées il faut mais
la violence
faut saluer la responsabilité des forces
syndicales qui ont bien encadré ces
manifestations et quand vous c'est pas
la même chose d'aller manifester quand
vous savez qu'il y aura de la violence
et au fond même si vous même vous n'avez
pas d'acte de violence vous vous rendez
d'une certaine façon dans l'amalgame de
la violence que d'être manifestants
syndiqué ou pas syndiqué d'ailleurs avec
des élus qui sont les aujourd'hui à
sainte-solin sont tes responsables ah
ils sont totalement irresponsables oui
je brûlés totalement
à vous assister à vous si vous
compagnonnez si vous marchez avec des
gens qui lancent des cailloux sur les
autres si vous n'êtes pas d'accord avec
eux il y a qu'une solution soit vous
vous êtes capable de les arrêter soit
vous sortez du cortège oh je sais pas ce
que j'ai vu j'ai vu des gens qui étaient
irresponsables et qui teneront voyant
Rome brûler se réjouissent j'ai vu les
tweets de Monsieur Mélenchon se
réjouissent de voir le feu il y a pas
assez réjouir de ça et quand on est élu
de la République quand on est
responsable quand on est député quand on
est responsable d'un parti personne
n'intera à faire le pirate pas le
pompier purement le pire romane tout
court et donc ces gens-là ils ont une
responsabilité j'en viens maintenant à
la manifestation de mardi mais je
distingue j'essaie de distinguer les
choses mais cette station il y a des
risques de violence on en a vu cette
semaine il y aura un dispositif qui sera
je crois ça a été dit par Gérald
Darmanin mon collègue de l'Intérieur qui
sera solide pour faire en sorte que ceux
qui veulent manifester puissent le faire
dans de bonnes conditions parce que à la
vérité quand vous avez de la violence
c'est à ceux qui portent une cause que
vous nuisez
vous dissocier sainte Soline sur le
ministre mais on a bien vu vous avez des
gens de Suisse d'Italie de fin juste
mais justement
et bien vu que lors de la dernière
manifestation contre les retraites ça a
été violent à Paris mais ça a été
violent aussi dans beaucoup de villes de
l'Ouest Nantes Rennes Saint-Nazaire tout
à l'heure en nous disait nos invités
Lorient van et des édifices publics qui
étaient pris pour six systématiquement
donc la porte de la mairie
par d'autres extrémistes donc ça veut
dire quand même que il y a une espèce de
sinon de convergence mais on voit bien
qu'il y a une installation du désordre
dans le dans le dans le pays oui
convergence en tout cas on voit une
image assez désastre personne ne vous
dira vous avez raison ça ne rend pas une
image positive
à rétablir l'ordre non il y a pas une
incapacité à l'intérieur parce que à
chaque fois on rétablit l'ordre infini
on rétablit l'heure mais quand vous avez
des gens qui courent les rues et qui se
promènent qui avec un cocktail Molotof
ou autre les forces de l'ordre font le
maximum de ce qu'il est possible de
faire pour préserver les personnes
d'abord contraire ment à ceux qui
manifestaient cet après-midi à
Sainte-Soline et pour préserver les
biens après on a des éléments qu'il faut
essayer de contrôler c'est c'est toute
la stratégie de maintien de l'ordre qui
a été mise en place
on a un besoin
jusqu'où va-t-on c'est ce que j'essaie
de faire y compris pour ceux qui me
connaissent en général c'est que il y a
besoin il y a aucune illégitimité à ne
pas être d'accord et à manifester jamais
vous entendrez dire ça je comprends
qu'il puisse avoir de l'incompréhension
et parfois même de la colère mais il y a
aucune légitimité à exercer la violence
et donc notre responsabilité collective
c'est pas une responsabilité que du
gouvernement notre responsabilité au
niveau du gouvernement c'est d'expliquer
de d'essayer d'apaiser les choses et
vous me voyez pas ce soir je vais lui
sur le feu c'est d'essayer d'expliquer
les choses et puis deux je pense que les
syndicats j'entends l'expression des
différents responsables syndicaux qui
essayent à la fois de marquer leur
mécontentement et leur désaccord et en
même temps de le faire dans le cadre
légal je voudrais juste peut-être
revenir sur sur un fait de cette journée
vous avez certainement entendu cette
extrait sonore vous vous évoquez la
sécurité la sécurité notamment dans les
routes de Paris à force de l'ordre
sont-elles sont-elles épuisées cette
vidéo qui circule sur les réseaux
sociaux et qui a été rendu public par
nos confrères du monde c'est
enregistrement sonore dans lequel
plusieurs policiers de la brave menace
intimide des jeunes des jeunes
interpellés dans la rue ça a été ça a
été assez violent je vous propose
d'écouter le témoignage d'une des
personnes qui a été interpellée au
voudrais voir votre réaction après
monsieur le ministre
c'était le soir de lundi après la
découverte de l'émotion de censure
rejetées je manifestais à Bastille j'ai
été interpellé violemment placé
arbitrairement en garde à vue et à ce
moment-là je suis rue de Béarn et je
j'entends la brave qui la brigade de
répression de l'action violente
motorisée arriver derrière moi donc là
il y a une gérer une quinzaine de
vingtaine de motards moi une quinzaine
qui arrive derrière et qui
me tombe dessus je me rends mains en
l'air parce que j'ai peur de me faire
matraquer et en fait il me balaye je
tombe d'eau contre les pavés et
il me menotte je j'entends un [__]
je demande comment et on se dit ta
gueule et ensuite on m'amène avec les
autres menottés et là on est tous
alignés et puis ça a été intimidation
sur intimidation avec des bavures autant
RAC
que sexiste en tout cas à mon égard plus
l'antisémitisme par rapport à mon prénom
j'ai vu donc les policiers de la brave
prendra partie le jeune garçon noir et
j'étais inquiète pour lui parce que
manifestement il connaissait pas
forcément ses droits donc c'est pour ça
qu'il répondait aux policiers qu'est-ce
qui a valu une surenchère raciste du
coup des des violences verbales
terribles et des connotations sexuelles
sur ces clairement c'est parti génitales
j'ai entendu les couilles de noir ce
genre de choses voilà on est on était
dans ce niveau là il y a plusieurs
témoignages qui vont dans ce sens en
uni-âge au préfet de police de Paris à
juger ses propos évidemment inacceptable
ligpn est saisie mais il y a beaucoup de
témoignages les bras aiment sont des
unités de policiers à moto dans la
mission en fait et d'aller au contact
des casseurs pour éviter que ça ça
dégénère quand on entend ce type de
témoignage vous le disiez effectivement
maintenir l'ordre et essayer de de faire
les choses correctement il y a aussi des
questions sur des débordements
maintenir l'ordre c'est compliqué ça
n'excuse pas du tout ce que ce que je
veux dire après mais maintenir l'ordre
c'est très compliqué quand vous avez des
éléments très violents et vous essayez
d'éviter qui en incendie qui est
dégradation qui des dégradations des
violences faites sur les personnes il
faut quand même saluer l'action des CRS
des gendarmes des policiers qui tous les
jours parfois en ce moment sont
confrontés à de la violence j'étais dans
les Pyrénées-Atlantiques vendredi et
j'avais face à moi des CRS qui avaient
reçu des cailloux et des pavés et c'est
une violence qui l'aurait fait deuxième
élément par rapport à ce que vous
évoquez
j'entends la parole de cette de cette
dame et il faut écouter la parole de
cette dame il y a du contradictoire dans
ses affaires là le préfet de lunès a
très bien dit les choses Gérald Darmanin
c'est c'est pas que des paroles qui sont
gênantes si tel était le cas c'est des
attitudes qui sont gênantes et donc si
c'était le cas à ce moment là ça mérite
sanction mais
il y a des faits de cette nature qui ne
sont pas la majorité des choses et il
faut aussi penser à tout ce qui se passe
dans le cadre qui celui de fixé par le
maintien de l'ordre et qui se fait dans
de bonnes conditions mais quand ça
dérape
évidemment il faut le dénoncer et
évidemment si c'est avéré il faut que
les sanctions doivent être prises soient
prises mais maintenir l'ordre c'est
quelque chose de très compliqué dans un
pays on dit toujours le la police et la
gendarmerie c'est la monopole de la
violence légitime elle s'exerce et elle
est acceptée dès lors qu'elle est
légitime et qu'elle s'exerce dans le
code déontologie de pratique dans ce
contexte de surenchère des violences
est-ce que le gouvernement peut faire un
geste d'ici mardi et la dixième journée
de mobilisation par exemple je pense à
la pose réclamée par Laurent Berger
Laurent Berger le leader de la CFDT il y
a un processus qui se poursuit qui est
maintenant que le texte est au Conseil
constitutionnel je crois que la première
ministre a redit encore cet après-midi
au Congrès d'horizon la volonté c'est
plutôt un volonté d'apaisement l'idée
d'une pause en permanence dès qu'on a un
sujet ne paraît pas une bonne une bonne
méthode mais il a pas il nous
appartiendra de réfléchir à la manière
dont on peut en tout cas de notre côté
apaiser les choses merci beaucoup merci
d'être venu sur le plateau de BFM TV ce
soir pour répondre à nos questions il
est 19h